[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: What we just
saw was bot power in action,
the ability to query
for information
from one or more sources and
have it summarize succinctly
for all in a chat room.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome to another episode
of the G Suite Dev show.
I'm your host, Wesley Chun.
I'm excited to introduce you
to the Hangouts Chat developer
platform in API.
Of course we can converse
with colleagues in chat rooms,
but making data requests
or automating work
at the same time is
much more powerful.
In today's intro video,
I'll show you not one,
but two ways of
building chat bots.
Let's start with the Hello
World for Hangouts Chat,
the echo bot.
Here you can see it's a full
one-line JavaScript glory.
As you can see, the function
name is called onMessage.
And it takes an event object,
as a result of the message that
was posted in the chat
room, and all our bot
does is greet the user and
echoes back what they wrote.
Can't get any easier than this.
Check the docs for a
slightly longer quickstart
for more info.
However, your bot will
likely be more complex.
So we need to investigate
writing bots a little further
before diving into more code.
The next step is to discuss some
basics on how to build a bot
and how they work.
We do this by
recognizing what happens
to bots, or in other words,
what events are sent to bots.
Once a bot is added
to a chat room,
users can interact with it.
When users message
a bot, Hangouts Chat
sends the message
to your bot, along
with a message type
and other data.
There are four message types.
ADDED_TO_SPACE is
the first message
a bot gets when it's added to a
room or a Direct Message or DM.
Your bot would typically
send back a message like,
thanks for adding
me to this room.
The second message type
is REMOVED_FROM_SPACE.
This is a message that's
received by the bot
after it has been removed
from a room, or a DM.
Since your bot's been
removed, there's no response.
MESSAGE is a normal message
that's sent by a user to a bot,
and these are the most
common, as you can imagine.
Your bot has to
service the request
and send back an
appropriate response.
The last message
type is CARD_CLICKED.
This means a user clicked on
an interactive card in Hangouts
Chat instead of
sending a message.
Your bot either sends an
appropriate response or updates
the UI card or maybe both.
JavaScript and Python are
two popular platforms,
so we'll demo bots
in each one for you.
The JavaScript runs
on Google Apps Script,
while its Python equivalent
runs on Google App Engine.
Apps Script has basic event
handling for developers
and calls the
appropriately-named function.
One of the reasons
why using Apps Script
is easier than other
platforms, you just
have to name your functions
with the exact names that
are supported for
each message type.
App Engine is a bit
lower level, so you
need to grab the request
body, parse a JSON payload,
and determine the message
type and contents.
In other words,
you need to check
all the events that come in and
see what message type it is.
Then take the
appropriate action.
Now it's time to talk
about our sample bot today.
Asking your colleagues
to vote on something
is fairly common, whether it
be who's going out to lunch
or who's in for the
basketball game after work.
Let's build a simple vote
bot by which participants
can issue an up or down vote,
as well as create a new vote.
Let's go to a computer so
I can show you this example
in both JavaScript and Python.
The samples we're looking at
in this Dev Bot video are both
available on GitHub, so
feel free to follow along
at
GitHub.com/gsuitedevs/hangouts
chat samples.
The bot we're implementing
is a text-only version
of the vote bot.
Let's look at it in
Apps Script first.
Here's what the vote
card looks like.
You'll see plus 1 and minus 1
buttons for up and down votes,
as well as a new button for
starting new votes, which
is the default action.
OK.
Now we can look at the
votetextbot.js script.
Scrolling down to
the bottom, you'll
see how Apps Script
processes the message types,
you know, ADDED_TO_SPACE,
REMOVED_FROM_SPACE,
MESSAGE, and CARD_CLICKED.
Well, it does so by calling the
corresponding similarly-named
On function we
looked at earlier.
In the vote bot,
we're only processing
MESSAGE and
CARD_CLICKED messages
and not taking any action
when the bot is added to
or removed from the space.
onMessage ignores
whatever message the user
has sent, creates a new
vote card, and returns it.
onCardClick is where
the real magic happens.
If new vote is selected, it
does the exact same thing
as when a user sends
any message to the bot.
It creates a new vote.
When up or down
vote are clicked,
those actions are passed as a
string parameter in the event
object along with the
current vote count, which
was converted to a string.
When the vote count
variable is created,
that value must first be
converted back to an integer
so that it can be
incremented on an up vote
or decremented on a down vote.
Now when the card payload is
created using createMessage,
the command to update the
current card only if a new vote
was not selected, meaning
an up or down vote.
Scrolling up to
createMessage, you'll
see that it converts that
vote count to a string,
as mentioned before, then
uses the shouldUpdate flag
to indicate a new
vote card, if true,
or update the existing
card otherwise,
meaning an up vote or down vote.
Then it pieces the card
together section by section
as JSON markup.
This gets returned to Hangouts
Chat, which then renders a card
to users in the chat room.
There are no surprises
when you run this example.
Clicking on plus 1 ups
the count, while minus 1
brings it down.
And NEW starts a new vote.
Now, if we hop up and over to
the Python App Engine version,
the core functionality is
also in a single file, bot.py,
plus the App Engine
app.yaml config file.
Scrolling down to
the bottom again,
you'll see that it's slightly
more lower level than Apps
Script version, because you have
to introspect the payload that
comes from the
HTTP post request.
There's an if, else
if, else that takes
the same actions as the
Apps Script version,
depending on the message type.
Similarly, there's an
analog to create message
that puts together the
corresponding JSON payload
returned to Hangouts Chat.
We won't run this version.
But trust me, it's
the same thing.
Overall, I find this
bot useful, because it's
a bit more useful than what
you get from the quickstarts,
and you get to learn
about interactive cards.
Not bad, right?
We picked Apps Script and
Python App Engine for a reason.
They require few lines
of code and are portable.
For example, the
Apps Script sample
can be ported to Cloud
functions or node.js
in a straightforward way.
Similarly, the Python example
can be ported to Flask.
Then you can run that
app on either App Engine
or your own stack.
You may have noticed
that bots work
a bit differently from
standard APIs, you know,
where your app gets some
input, say, from a website
or other form of input.
And then you're up with
the proper credentials.
We'll make a call to the API,
which processes the requests,
and then sends back a
response, to which you
respond to your user-- you know,
typical client server stuff.
But bots are a
little bit different
in that the original
request comes
from a user in a
chat room, which
means Hangouts Chat is
what gets the message,
and its servers
contact your apps.
You service the request
and respond back
to Hangouts Chat, which then
renders your response back
into the chat room.
All right.
The roles are almost
reversed, meaning
your bot is kind of
like the API, servicing
requests made in chat rooms.
Does that makes sense?
All right.
So that means that bots
generally live on some server
somewhere.
Now let's talk where.
A wide variety of platforms
that host bots are supported.
I'll argue that Google
Apps Script is the easiest
to get started with.
You code in JavaScript, but
more importantly, Apps Script,
gives you and your data
and your bot access
to data and functionality from
Gmail, Google Drive, Calendar,
Docs, Sheets, Slides, and more.
Best of all, Apps
Script is serverless,
meaning that Google
hosts your app.
So you don't need to submit
up your own VM or other stack
components.
If you want to code in
JavaScript, but more like Node,
but also stay serverless,
you have two options.
Want tighter integration with
the Google Cloud Platform,
or GCP for short,
instead of G Suite?
Well, then choose
Google Cloud Functions.
Building a mobile app or a
mobile web app with Firebase?
Well, then choose Cloud
Functions for Firebase.
Want to read more
about these choices?
Well, check this
page in the docs
and realize they're both
the same product, but tuned
for either the
cloud or Firebase.
Still want to live in
the land of serverless,
but want more choices
and languages?
Then consider Google App
Engine, platform as a service,
or app hosting in the cloud.
We showed you Python
earlier, but App Engine also
supports Java,
PHP, Go, and more.
Need more control?
Well, then you're going
to have to spin up
a VM to host your bot.
You can use Google Compute
Engine or any public or private
cloud provider.
Now that you may have noticed,
we didn't do any authorization,
nor did we use the
Hangouts Chat API.
That's because we created
a synchronous bot,
meaning it was able to
pull in those sales numbers
and respond back to
the user immediately.
Some queries may take longer or
have to talk to more systems.
In those cases,
you can build a bot
that responds asynchronously
when results are ready.
In these cases, you would use
the API or other technique
for responding back
to the chat room.
We'll take a look at
those in another video.
For now, we want you to
have enough to get started.
Check out the first link to
learn more about bot concepts.
The next link is for those
who want to learn more
about actually building bots.
Finally, if you're not
ready to build bots yet
but want to see
more examples, we've
got a page in the
docs for you too.
Got your vote bot working and
want to break out to the box?
Well, here's a
challenge for you.
Make any or all of these
five additional upgrades.
One, add images.
Two, keep track of who
has voted and who hasn't.
Three, don't let the
vote count go below zero.
Four, only allow down votes
from users who have at least one
up vote.
And five, the user
who starts a new vote
should be able to
choose a topic,
you know, like lunch,
after-work game, and so on.
By the way, the first one has
already been done for you.
So check it out in the docs
page on interactive cards.
Hope you're ready
to build some bots.
No longer are chat rooms
just for conversations.
With feature-rich,
intelligent bots,
users can automate tasks,
get critical information,
or do other heavy lifting
with just a simple message.
We're excited at the
possibilities that
await both developers and G
Suite users on the new Hangouts
Chat developer platform.
Be sure to subscribe
to our channel,
and tune in again next time.
This is Wesley Chun from Google,
and we'll see you next time
upstairs in the G Suite.
[MUSIC PLAYING]